before the video starts guys i've come
together mostly made once again to get
clean water for families in gaza 105
pounds can provide
interrupted water to two families for an
entire year
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
brothers and sisters and dear friends
yes you're thinking all right looks it
looks a little bit different there yes
we've got some new shades i've got
another one actually but at the end you
can tell which one looks better
and we've got some for the shine as well
so in this next video you might see it
it looks it looks like a real genius
look at my boss
anyways promises this video is about
khabib and we know
mcgregor and khabib they find their
little back and forth inshallah we can
see from mcgregor's action what kind of
person he is
and from khabib's action the way he
carries himself with his principles and
as a muslim
um his values and what kind of person is
in this very interview he's reacting to
mcgregor
breaking his ankle and um here's what he
had to say and there's two things he
mentions
and these two things remind me of two
specific verses in the quran
let's watch and let's learn a lesson
inshallah here we go i ask
you're always going to be associated
with conor mcgregor did you watch the
fight did you see
how it played out and hear the things
afterwards and what were your thoughts
in the whole situation of course i watch
fight
i really enjoy with fight honestly you
know
this fight show us
we it's it's it's gonna be always there
like something like superior
more powerful than we have you know and
sometimes when people become like oh
and do this i can do this because
of i'm smart because i'm strong like
god gonna make you always humble and you
okay
just stop there the first verse that it
reminds me of is this
verse 37 and allah subhanahu wa says god
almighty says in the quran and walk not
on the earth
with conceit and arrogance verily you
can neither rent nor penetrate the earth
nor can you attain a statue like the
mountains in height god almighty is
telling us to reflect upon his creation
because once you acknowledge that he
exists
and if you walk in an arrogant way yeah
like pharaoh did yeah because he felt
himself to be a god
he felt himself to be divine why because
he had so much wealth
and this is the power of having so much
things and we think that's a blessing if
it was a blessing
god almighty god almighty would have
grant paradise to pharaoh because he had
everything
and no it doesn't work like that god it
doesn't mean god loves you when he gives
you everything you want
and it shows you that it gives you
arrogance as well so god doesn't want
sin you can't you're walking on the
earth
you can't break it apart with your feet
you know and don't walk like you
boasting you know because look at the
mountains and look how small you are
so that's a reminder to you now the
second part of this video
it says another interesting thing which
goes to another verse in surah cafe
it was like like i saw like yesterday or
two days ago i i just saw
uh his uh coach interview you say
i don't understand how this happened
like he's like
strong young man and he broke his foot
like i don't understand
everything from that you have to be
humble you know
when you become like rich when you
become strong when you become
more famous and and then you think
this is because of myself that's gonna
make him humble you know
and i really enjoy with this fight
honestly i really
okay good now this uh is from soraka
verse
32 god almighty is telling us about a
parable of two
uh specific instant not in a parallel
this two incident instance that happened
in the quran and presented them an
example of two men we granted to one of
them two gardens
of grapevines and we bought them with
palm trees and placed between them uh
one so one of them with two gardens
between them were filled and crops
each of the two gardens produced its
fruit and did not fall short they're off
in anything
and we caused to gush forth within them
a river
and he had fruit so he said to his
companion while he was conversing with
him
i am greater than you in wealth and
mightier in
um in numbers of men look at the
arrogance look how allah connects
the blessings god almighty gave him not
by himself
and look how he gets how so arrogant
that to his neighbor he's saying i am
more wealthy than you and greater in man
and he entered his garden while he was
unjust to himself now being unjust
yourself means you're wronging yourself
by arrogance don't be arrogant because
no one will enter paradise with the atom
way of arrogance and we know why satan
fell into disbelief because of his
arrogance and his arrogance led him to
attributing a mistake to allah
he said i do not think that this would
perish ever
so he's under the assumption that no one
can take this away from me why because
he's
trusting himself and you know as as long
as i have water and i'm god then how
could this ever stop that's the
mentality
which is wrong this is thinking with
this logic but it doesn't know what to
pan or tala
can do things and i do not think that i
will occur and even if it
if i should be brought back to my lord i
will surely find the find better than
this has returned kind of arrogance yeah
denying certain signs his companion said
to him while he was conversing with him
so the guy he was talking to
and belittling him have you disbelieved
that he who created you from a dust
and then from a sperm drop and then
proportioned you as a man
but as for me he is allah my lord and i
do not associate with my lord anyone
and why did you when you enter your god
did not say oh inshallah what allah will
there is no power except in allah
although you see me less than you
in wealth and children so he's this man
who's
not as rich as him is telling him why
you're not saying you're praising god
almighty
and bossing about yourself it's maybe
that your lord will give me something
better than you
better than your garden and will send
upon it a penalty from the sky and it
will become a smooth dusty ground
look what happens next or its water will
become sunken into the earth so you
would never be able to speak of it
and his fruits were encompassed by ruin
so he began to turn his hands about and
dismay
over what he had spent on it while it
had collapsed upon his
transistors and said oh i wish i had not
associated with my lord anyone
and there was for him no company to aid
him other than allah
nor could he defend himself that's the
authority
uh is completed for allah the truth he
is the best in the world and the best in
outcome
i can just summon up with this verses
what khabib said about the conor
mcgregor situation allah
wool is reminding you of arrogance and
he's giving you reminders over and over
again
and there's a verse in quran and i wrap
up with this allah says he will send the
smaller
calamity to divert a little calamity he
will send these punishments
or these things as a reminder for you to
wake up the more arrogant you get
then allah will close your heart yes so
as we can see promises i have never seen
anybody turn to allah when they have
wealth and staff and all this kind of
stuff no they become arrogant but i've
seen
hundreds and thousands of people who
have turned out subtitles based on
calamity loss of wealth
loss of life um whatever it may be allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
and don't see this as allah hits you
allah loves you that's why he is giving
you this trial
so you can turn to him you turn you to
allah
fix your affairs with allah allah will
fix your affairs with the people and
with your life
give your uh allah and watch how your
life and everything falls into place
until next time assalamu alaikum welcome
to a better category by the way guys do
that
this classes as you can see i changed
them or
these ones i bought for them i'm not
keen on that this one but this one look
maybe the 1980s mafia boss you know
maybe someone from gta
until next time goodbye